les humains cultivent les pommes depuis
des milliers d'années et il est modifie
grâce à des croisements successifs le
fruit dans lequel on croque aujourd'hui
et beaucoup plus gros beaucoup plus
sucré et moins acide que la pomme
ancestrale et cette évolution n'est pas
prête de s'arrêter
[Musique]
toute ma vie
dans la péninsule du Niagara hard Morier
savoure la pomme tous les jours dans son
verger il le fait depuis plus de 50 ans
[Musique]
hiver je suis dehors c'est ma passion
ma femme dit qu'il serait temps de
prendre ma retraite mais pour faire quoi
je préfère être dans le verger plutôt
que d'être dans une résidence pour
personnes âgées
comme la majorité des pomiculteurs il
cultivent des variétés de pommes qui
sont dictées par le marché
il y a 30 ans planter des variétés comme
la délicieuse rouge ou la Macintosh de
ces variétés sont beaucoup moins
populaires qu'avant donc on les cultive
de moins en moins
il y a de nouvelles variétés par exemple
la gala qui vient de la Nouvelle-Zélande
[Musique]
les pommes que nous consommons sont le
fruit d'une très très longue évolution
d'un très long voyage
il faut reculer d'environ 7000 ans pour
découvrir l'ancêtre de la pomme que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui
cette pomme possède à l'état sauvage
dans les montagnes tiennent Chan dans la
région de ce qui est aujourd'hui le
Kazakhstan
depuis cette époque les humains ont fait
voyager la pomme d'est en ouest tout le
long de la rue de la soie cette
migration engendrait un tas de
croisement qui a donné la pomme que nous
consommons aujourd'hui
[Musique]
les croisements ont été faits par les
humains mais parfois ils étaient
accidentelles grâce aux insectes
pollinisateurs donc les améliorations et
certains de ces règles nous avons dans
les pommes aujourd'hui sont
accidentelles
aujourd'hui il existe plusieurs milliers
de variétés de pommes à travers le monde
de ce nombre seulement une douzaine se
retrouve sur les tablettes des
supermarchés
la plupart des variétés qu'on trouve en
supermarché sont issus de la sélection
ça fait 200 ans qu'on travaille
améliorer la productivité et le goût des
fruits
[Musique]
à la composition génétique et à l'ADN
des pommes dans un verger d'agriculture
Canada à quelle ville en Nouvelle-Écosse
il a accès à une immense base de données
plus de 1000 variétés de pommes
provenant de partout à travers le monde
ces données génétiques peuvent servir à
d'autres chercheurs ailleurs au Canada
qui veulent faire des croisements afin
de développer une meilleure pomme
vous pouvez améliorer une pomme pour
qu'elle goûte ou sans meilleur pour
qu'elle se conserve plus longtemps mais
vous pouvez également améliorer la
polyculture de manière plus large pour
qu'elle soit plus durable ou mieux
adapté au climat ou à la sécheresse
ainsi les améliorations touchent
l'ensemble du système et la façon dont
nous mangeons
dans son verger hard Morieux demeure à
l'affût des tendances c'est pourquoi il
participe aux efforts de recherche en
permaculture
de pommes créées à la station de
recherche
on m'a demandé si je voulais planter ces
pommiers nous sommes 11 pointiculteurs
ontariens à participer à la recherche
[Musique]
les pommiers à les sèche chez hartmore
proviennent d'ici le centre de recherche
devant tout près de Niagara c'est l'un
des deux seuls centres de recherche
spécialisés dans la création de
nouvelles variétés de pommes au pays
l'autre centre est à Summerland dans la
vallée de au Canada
ici sont différents il faut donc les
éclaircir manuellement on essaie de
garder une trentaine de fruits par arbre
ce qui est suffisant pour les évaluer
les recherches en développement de
nouvelles variétés de pommes
nous avons lancé notre programme en 2011
à partir de rien nous avons sondé les
consommateurs pour essayer de comprendre
ce qu'il recherchait dans une pomme
on essaie d'obtenir la pomme parfaite et
pour ça il faut faire beaucoup beaucoup
d'essais on a dû crier jusqu'à
maintenant pas loin de 35000 arbres
différents c'est ce que ça prend pour
trouver les très rares bons spécimens
pour arriver à développer une pomme que
les consommateurs voudront acheter une
équipe en laboratoire fait plusieurs
analyses sur ces milliers de pommes à
l'essai on l'étudie les niveaux de sucre
l'acidité et même les odeurs et aromes
l'odeur peut influencer notre perception
du sucre ainsi une pomme moins sucrée
mais avec un parfum agréable peut donner
l'impression d'être meilleur au goût
ensuite vient le moment de goûter chaque
semaine des goutteurs professionnels
sont les premiers à croquer dans ces
nouvelles pommes
[Musique]
si elles sont choisies par une très
grande majorité lors de nos deux séances
de dégustation on les reproduit dans ce
verger juste derrière moi
et donc devant ses arbres qui pourraient
fournir les pommes de demain son
expérience lui dit déjà ce que le
consommateur veut
de tout si la pomme est d'un beau rouge
vif les gens l'aimeront c'est pas
nécessairement que les meilleurs qu'une
autre c'est vraiment une question
d'apparence les consommateurs veulent
des pommes parfaites sans tache ni
piqûres d'insectes il faut le dire les
Nord-Américains sont choyés et on
l'embarras du choix
le travail de sélection des 200
dernières années c'est vraiment
concentré sur le goût des consommateurs
on a développé de belles grosses pommes
symétriques colorées et qui se mange
facilement elles sont fermes sucrées
juteux
[Musique]
le résultat de tous ces croisements est
majeurs les pommes d'aujourd'hui sont
presque quatre fois plus grosses que
leurs ancêtres elles sont en moyenne 40%
moins acides et elle contient environ
70% moins de composés phénoliques
non
sont en partie responsables de
l'amertume et du brunissement de la
chair puisqu’on mange aussi avec les
yeux cet aspect peut en rebuter plus
d’être
mais la diminution de ses composés
phénoliques signifie aussi une baisse de
l'effet antioxydant des pommes un
élément important pour notre santé
[Musique]
moins de phénols que leurs ancêtres vous
connaissez sans doute le dicton une
pomme par jour est loin le médecin pour
toujours et bien maintenant ce serait
plutôt deux pommes par jour et loin le
médecin pour toujours et puis si vous
cherchez un fort taux de finale vous
vous rendez au Kazakhstan et vous mangez
des pommes sauvages elles sont souvent
acides amères et tanniques je suis pas
certain vous les aimerez mais elles
seront bourrées d'antioxydants
la pomme est en constante évolution car
la science évolue chaque jour après tout
c'est la recherche d'un équilibre entre
santé écologie et bon goût c'est la
quête de développer une pomme plus
résistante aux maladies qui demandent
beaucoup moins de traitements chimiques
mais que les consommateurs voudront
acheter
peut-être devrions-nous revenir à
certaines variétés anciennes et les
retravailler avec la génétique je crois
que ça vaut la peine d'essayer pour voir
ce qu'on peut trouver
l'histoire de la sélection végétale
n'aura jamais fin puisque l'humain
cherchera toujours mieux mais tout ça
prend du temps pour une pomme c'est
environ 25 ans c'est un effort qu'on
répète depuis des milliers d'années et
qu'on se transmet de génération en
génération et ça se poursuivra puisqu'on
améliorera encore les variétés
sélectionnera de nouveaux traits on
adaptera la permiculture à différents
climats et environnement
[Musique]
c'est formidable de penser que dans 20
30 40 ans ma famille ou mes descendants
pourraient manger une variété de pommes
issue de la recherche qu'on aura fait
ici